I'm tied to the Bison saying of course
not you to beg of course right spot it
was going to be a big hit but I so you
and when you were in it do you think oh
this is a job or did you kind of know
who this is a good film this is a really
fun well I had been walking on the stage
play originally and playing humor
Douglas Park in a stage play and every
night we were getting phenomenal
immediate response from audiences so I
knew the material really was hit in an
hour and I was confident that this film
was going to be a strong piece and
people were going to respond to it
because I was seeing that every night on
stage but none of us had any conception
of the skill the profound effect an
impact that it was going to make on the
culture and it was it was kind of
overwhelming for myself and I think
probably for all of us
when you had the full monty come in just
like clockwork
just like the next minute so you were
you were writing like sort of double
tidal wave but a good thing you do meant
to the poor monkey so the you know
talking about you don't know something's
a hit when you're in it you really
didn't see hit written on full monty
it's all the [__] fish
it was a tough shoot full monty the
posture I really was I never help mind a
horrible one
I save it's so horrible that when the
the people Fox Searchlight who'd made it
they saw the Faust kata this thing and
they went straight to video
ahhh Wow it was just very very tough and
the guy did the adjustable timing belt
oh he can a big Forks first but I said
look we've got a hundred movies here
this guy's short the ass off first
yeah it'll give us a chance you know so
he and did they can I get get under the
Edit that they get under the director
and Umberto and Nick Miller they grow on
as an editor they cut together what you
saw and thus thing went from with almost
3d video today is taking a bit four
hundred million or something to the
officers it was to see all it was up for
it was up against our tannic and what
launched crazy yeah it was amazing yes
not you
[Music]